diversity inclusion is something that
has been around and companies for
decades now and generally people think
of it as diversity and inclusion but I
would actually challenge that given that
I think that historically we've seen
diversity or inclusion rather than
diversity and inclusion and what I mean
by that is that companies really want
inclusion but they often predicate that
inclusion on the surrender of various
forms of diversity that people bring to
the table so the idea is that if you
modulate your outsider identity to adopt
mainstream behaviors and you'll be
included and so it puts people to this
tragic choice between their identity and
inclusion and that's where I think that
companies have missed the mark or need
to update their practices so I look at
the notion of authenticity through
Erving Goffman's term covering so Erving
Goffman was the sociologist who wrote
back in the 1960s and his notion of
covering was the way in which we all
modulate our identities in order to be
accepted by the mainstream so when I
first came across this term my immediate
response was how does covering differ
from passing and one of the great things
about Goffman is that he's such a good
writer that when you're reading him you
almost feel like you're talking to him
so the next paragraph was you know the
astute reader may be asking himself how
covering differs from passing and he
gives the example of President Franklin
Delano Roosevelt and Roosevelt used to
always make sure that he was seated
behind a table before his cabinet
entered so he wasn't passing because
everybody knew that he had a motor
function disability and was confined to
a wheelchair but he was covering making
sure his more conventional presidential
qualities I'm white I'm a man were in
the foreground and his less conventional
presidential quality I'm a person with
the disability was in the background of
the interaction and whether it's on the
basis of race or gender or sexual
orientation or religion or disability
all of us engage and these practices
where we downplay the things that push
us outside of the mainstream and that as
our study again shows comes at a
significant cost to people's sense of
self so you know I'm a rubber hits the
road
kind of guy so even if we find a high
incidence of this practice of covering
which we found that 61% of individuals
reported covering I kind of thought well
I don't care about this unless people
report that it's harmful to them if
people say I do it but it's not a big
deal then I don't care but sixty to
seventy three percent of individuals
depending on the particular axis of
covering that we looked at said that
this is somewhat too extremely
detrimental to their sense of self so
that's something that we really need to
be attentive to if we want people to
really flourish in whatever organization
they inhabit the prevalence of covering
is something that we often get asked
about and the distribution of which
groups cover more which groups cover
less and I have both the intuitive and a
counterintuitive answer to that so the
intuitive answer is you know groups that
are seen as struggling to make it into
the mainstream have a much higher
reported incidence of covering so 83% of
LGB respondents in our survey lesbian
gay and bisexual respondents in our
survey reported covering 79% of blacks
both African Americans and non nationals
right 66% of women right so that array I
think will strike many listeners as
intuitive but on the other hand we also
found that 45% of straight white men
reported covering on at least one of the
dimensions that we articulate in our
paper and that was obviously a really
interesting statistic to us and so we
dug in more deeply to think about well
what are the ways in which straight
white men who are traditionally seen as
outside of the inclusion paradigm what
are the ways in which they cover and we
discovered everything from I have to
cover my religion to I have to cover my
political affiliation I have to cover my
veteran status or my working-class
background or I have to cover the fact
that I have a mental or physical illness
so we really ran the gamut and the
reason that that statistic was so
important to us is that straight white
men are often either lionized or
demonized in these conversations they're
either lofted up as a people who were
supposed to come riding and to fix
everything or at worst
people who are you know supposed to
clean up their own mess and people who
cause a problem they're demonized the
notion is that straight white men cover
and that this is a really really
important finding because it puts them
inside of the inclusion paradigm so when
I presented these results to CEOs to
executive committees to chief diversity
officers this is a statistic that
everybody gloms on to because the
straight white men in the room as one of
them put it to me this is finally a
paradigm of inclusion in which I can see
myself so I'm not outside looking in I'm
actually in this right another way to
put that would be to say that oftentimes
when I gave early iterations of this
research on covering one response that I
often got was I understand why people
should not have to be discriminated
against and based on things that they
can't change about themselves like say
their skin color or their chromosomes or
if it is immutable their sexual
orientation but why shouldn't you have
to cover because I have to cover all the
time I call this the angry straight
white guy question because the angry
straight white man used to always ask it
of me and one of them really sort of hit
me and in the face not literally but
sort of cognitively when he said look I
just survived cancer like I'm in
remission from cancer so no matter how
much you struggled with any of these
identities that you talk about no matter
how much other people struggle with
regard to covering a disability or their
sexual orientation or their gender like
I can't talk about my cancer nor could I
talk about it when I was going through
it lest I be perceived as overly weak so
it didn't pass I did tell people but I
didn't emphasize it because I didn't
want people to think well he's not gonna
be around or to write me off so the
minute that you say I acknowledge that
and I acknowledge that your claim to
authenticity your claim to human
flourishing
you know the burden of secrecy is as
great for you as it is for me that's a
moment when you actually can create a
bridge and that's a moment at which all
of that resentment which can often be
hidden among straight white men because
they get again pilloried if they talk
about it
right suddenly turns into solidarity the
moment that you can say yes you do this
too and wouldn't it be a better
workplace if you didn't have to do this
either
and you also have a secret self and
wouldn't it be better if you didn't have
to hide that secret self that's when you
get buy-in and that's when the
organization is forward